um
ah
uh
good afternoon everyone i really
couldn't be more honored to be here
celebrating this landmark collaboration
today
between johnson and johnson merck and
the biden administration
to further accelerate production of our
one
shot jansen johnson and johnson covenant
teen vaccine
i want to give a big thanks to president
biden having us here today
and for his leadership effort to johnson
and johnson's
135 000 employees and our global
partners
for the really external effort and
expertise that have gone in
to making sure our covit 19 vaccine
reaches as many corners of the world
as quickly as possible and also
to my good friend ken frazier and to
merck
for their partnership and for his
personal friendship over the years
you know our industry it's realizing the
early days of the pandemic
the vaccine development it wasn't
a race against each other's as
competitors
it's really a race against time to
defeat a common enemy
today we're at war with covet 19
and public private partnerships like the
historic one that we're celebrating
today
well their main reason that last week i
was privileged enough to witness some of
the very first
residents in our home state of new
jersey
receiving dose
since just 13 months 13 months
after we started the development process
when one of the residents
this senior apartment was asked how she
felt after her she after
uh she was given the shot she looked at
me in reply
safe it couldn't be i couldn't be more
proud
in our new collaboration with merck it's
going to allow us to even be more
ambitious
in our goals of keeping as many people
around the world as safe as we possibly
can
with our effective one-dose vaccine
so i'm proud extremely proud to count
ken frazier
as an active partner as we bring our
companies together
in new ways on behalf of humanity
we share one common goal above all
things
and that is advancing public health so
please join me
in welcoming ken frazier
mr president i want to begin by thanking
you
for the steady practical and resolute
leadership
you and your administration have
provided
putting people before politics and
fostering an
environment in which private sector
manufacturing and scientific
capabilities
can work in healthy partnership with
government
to create a force multiplier in a battle
we simply must win
i'm also pleased to be here alongside my
friend and colleague alex gorsky
to talk about our historic collaboration
the covet 19 pandemic has affected
all areas of our global community
it has created profound challenges and
hardships
especially for our most vulnerable and
disadvantaged people
and communities it has also shown a lot
on the resilience of our first
responders
scientists health care workers and those
providing
essential community services the real
heroes of this challenging moment
at merck we are proud to contribute to
the global response to the pandemic
through this collaboration with our
colleagues at johnson and johnson
and the biden administration we will
work together
to enable more timely delivery of much
needed medicines and vaccines for the
pandemic
now some observers may view this core
partnership
as the coming together of rivals but in
these extraordinary times
we are colleagues not competitors
the funding made available by the biden
administration
will enable us to adapt our
manufacturing facilities
for the production of covet 19 vaccines
and medicines including johnson and
johnson's
vaccine with the support of the biden
administration
and specifically the dpa we will
expedite the modification of our
equipment
again i want to thank president biden
alex gorsky and his colleague at
jonathan and johnson's for their
remarkable scientific achievements
and my colleagues within merc for
helping to facilitate
this important partnership and now
it is my distinct honor to introduce the
man
who has brought the full weight of the
federal government to bear fighting this
virus
president joe biden
well i thank you both for those words
you know you and i knew one another
i wasn't president you weren't a
chairman we ride back and forth
on ambach he lived in philadelphia was
commuting to wilmington
it's good to see you both here and thank
both of your kind words
i want to thank scientists and
researchers to johnson and johnson
for the literal heroic effort that began
when co-19 first spread and led to the
safe and effective vaccine
that are now being co-produced today
we're seeing two health companies
competitors
each with over 130 years of experience
coming together to help write a more
hopeful chapter in our battle against
covet 19.
i just had an opportunity to meet with
both the ceos and with their senior
operating officers
and to hear about the work they're doing
together
to produce vaccines substitute and
accelerate
what they call to take it to full finish
you know what's clear is this is
historic
nearly unprecedented collaboration
during world war
ii one of the country's slogans was
we are all in this together we are all
in this together and the companies took
that slogan to heart
for example one automaker didn't have
the capacity to build enough jeeps the
competitors stepped in to help competing
line makers teamed up and they produced
parts for each other and gave the
american pilots
as a consequence that control of the
skies
today we're seeing the same type of
collaboration
when it comes to getting this virus
under control i said
that it treats like a war so i want to
thank
the two companies for showing how we can
come together and defeat this virus
by putting patriotism and public health
first
and i mean that literally putting
patriotism and public health first
you're coming to mc working closely with
a man you both privately knew over
uh bragged about jeff zions jeff is in
the front row here i want to thank you
jeff and the hunter kova team
you put together for the coordination of
our covert 19 response and dr
david kessler and his team at the
department of health and human services
you know when i came into office we
began working with the team of j to
accelerate
and add capacity to their manufacturing
production efforts
and it became clear that merck one of
the world's leading vaccine
manufacturers
was in a position to be the partner we
needed in this effort
in this wartime effort i've not
hesitated to use my power under the
defense prediction act
to expedite critical materials and
vaccine production
such as equipment machinery and supplies
and it's not just johnson and johnson
and merck
pfizer moderna also work closely with us
to help speed up
the delivery of millions more doses the
result
is that we're now on track have enough
vaccine supply
for every american adult by the end of
may months earlier than anyone expected
hey i'm directing jeff and my hhs team
produce another 100 million doses
purchase another 100 million dose of the
johnson and johnson vaccine
i'm doing this because in this wartime
effort we need maximum flexibility
there's always a chance that we'll
encounter unexpected challenges
or we'll be a new need for a vaccine
effort or vaccination effort
a lot can happen a lot can change
and we need to be prepared and of course
we need to match the miracle of science
and the skill of manufacturing
with the massive logistical undertaking
of vaccinating over 300 million
americans
already we have gone from johnson and
johnson vaccine authorization to shots
in the arm
in three days i was telling the
gentleman we were at a facility
yesterday of veterans outreach
and there were four
there were three members of the veterans
community
getting shots one was getting
each of the three vaccines and the guy
in the middle of veteran
was getting his and i was standing about
as far away as i am from you
and standing up and he was sitting down
and as the nurse put in his arm he went
jay and jay just won
[Laughter]
well there's millions of people are
going to feel that way and be proud to
have
be in a position that they're an ability
to get the kind of help they need
seven weeks ago only eight percent of
the seniors
those most vulnerable to covet 19 have
received the vaccination today
60 of the people over the age of 65 or
older
have received at least one shot and
that's because
this is the population that represents
80 percent
of the of the coven 19 deaths we've
opened us
we've opened support and opened excuse
me and supported more than 500
community vaccination sites that's more
and and they're administering hundreds
of thousands of shots a day
and for folks who aren't near a pharmacy
or a mass vaccination center we're
deploying mobile clinics
like vans that go into places to meet
the folks where they live
we're also supplying vaccines to
community health centers
to reach those who have been hit the
hardest and suffered the most especially
black latino native american and rural
communities
and this is important because we know
we have more to do to ensure everyone is
treated with equity
and those most impacted get the care
they deserve
on saturday we hit a record of 2.9
million vaccinations in one day in
america
and beyond the numbers of the stories
the father
says he no longer fears for his daughter
when she leaves to go to work at the
hospital
the children are now able to hug their
grandparents
the vaccines bring hope and healing in
so many ways
again a vaccinated american is the only
way to beat the pandemic
get our economy back on track and for us
to get back our lives and our loved ones
you know that's why the american rescue
plan was so critical i want to thank
speaker pelosi and house of
representatives today for passing
the bill and i will be signing into law
shortly
this bill represents a historic historic
victory for the american people
i look forward to signing it later this
week everything in the american rescue
plan
addresses a real need including
investments to fund our entire
vaccination effort
more vaccines more vaccinators
and more vaccination sites millions more
americans will get tested
including home testing schools will soon
have the funding and resources that
reopen
safely on national imperative the
american rescue plan
the partnership between johnson and
johnson and merck
proves we can do big things important
things in this country
you know i'll let me conclude with this
tomorrow night
i'm going to prime time address the
american people
and talk about what we've been through
as a nation this past year
but more importantly i'm going to talk
about what comes next
i'm going to launch the next phase of
the covet response and explain
what we will do as a government and what
we will ask of the american people
there is light at the end of this dark
tunnel in the past year
but we cannot let our guard down now or
assume the
victory is inevitable together we're
going to get through this pandemic
and usher in a healthier and hopeful
future
so there is real reason for hope folks
there's real reason for hope i promise
you
may god bless you all may god protect
our troops
and may god ease the pain in the heart
of so many who've lost
so many people in this pandemic thank
you and
i really that we're going to do this
we're going to get it done thank you
mr president what do you plan to do with
the surplus what will you do with the
surplus
[Music]
the surplus will if we have a surplus
we're going to share it with the rest of
the world
we've already decided we're going to
work with
the outfit kovacs we've committed 4
billion to help
get the funding for more vaccines around
the world
this is not something that can be
stopped by a fence no matter how high
you build a fence or a wall
so we're not going to be ultimately safe
until the world is safe
and so we're going to start off making
sure americans are taken care of first
but we're then going to try to help the
rest of the world thank you is there a
crisis at the border
you